hey guys
so i wanted to put this out as actually
i didn't really want to put this out as
an announcement but because i have a
somewhat public life i thought it was
necessary
so that i can
clarify things and then not talk about
it as much going forward
andre and i are getting divorced
we've been
separated off and on for the last three
years as you guys may or may not know i
had scarlet so i had my daughter when i
was fairly young
nowadays 24
and the last
five years have been absolutely absurd
with
my health problems my autoimmune
disorder this strange diet seems to have
put in into remission
my mom getting sick my dad
getting sick both of them nearly dying
and
random
you know fame having to do with my dad
and so it was a lot to navigate for
anybody
i haven't talked about it because it's
not something
any person would be
totally okay with sharing with people
that they don't know on the internet but
i thought it was necessary anyway so i'm
not going to get into too many details
we've moved i've made this clear in
other videos we've moved to nashville so
andre and i are both here we're
co-parenting scarlett's at a new school
which has been absolutely amazing
compared to the school she was at in
toronto there are no masks there
it's great anyway um
things are amicable
as amicable as can be navigating a
divorce which is
really difficult to navigate
takes a lot of effort for both parties
in order to keep things amicable but
things are amicable
we you know there's no court or anything
we've been using mediators so that's all
good
you know as good as it can be
i think that's all i really want to say
it has not been
easy you know we tried to make it work
for
six years because
nobody
wants to have a kid and then
get divorced
with the kid
so
however
where i'm at now i'm
this is a harder video
and i don't have notes or anything so
i'm just talking
if that's not obvious but
i'm doing really well given the
circumstances
i'm
calmer and happier than i've been
probably in 25 years realistically but
i'm really happy with where i am
so
that's my announcement
i'm probably not going to talk about it
a lot in the future but
hopefully that covered anything and
doesn't leave anybody with too bad of a
taste in their mouth
yeah i think that's it